now I'm being accused of like like crazy
stuff okay
like put yourself in my shoes
now at four the video brought to you
first from our 8 news now investigators
public administrator Rob Tellis who is
now accused of murder arguing with
police officers during a prior arrest
outside his home good afternoon thanks
for joining us I'm Kirsten Joyce 8 news
now investigator David charns was first
to bring you the videos on 8newsnow.com
and he shows us Rob tell us reminded
officers several times that voters
elected him
foreign
take me down because I'm a public
official I did not touch anybody I
haven't heard anybody I am just being a
pro Clark County public administrator
Rob Tellis argues with Las Vegas metro
police officers as they take him into
custody on a domestic violence charge
you're not tell me who I am on this
night in 2020 the family of the elected
official now accused of murdering a Las
Vegas investigative reporter barricaded
themselves in a room who the hell did I
hit the video show an intoxicated Telus
arguing with officers as they take him
into custody on charges of domestic
violence battery and resisting a public
officer the domestic battery charge was
later dismissed I love my family I love
my wife the videos show Telus being
handcuffed searched and driven to jail
have a seat in the car he says several
times he's a public official I'm a
public official and I mean you know that
and I'm I'm not trying to be like I'm
Robert official so yeah do what I want
you I'm saying I'm not a idiot a judge
later sentencing Telus to a 90-day
suspended sentence on the resisting
charge ordering him to take an online
class the charge was later dismissed in
2021 following teles's completion of
that class I mean like seriously like
there is sufficient evidence to book me
right now there is sufficient evidence
to book you right now yes
you're very certain about that I am very
certain about that as for his current
case Telus is due in court next week on
his most recent charge of murder I'm
David charns eight news now
you can watch the videos and get alerted
to breaking news as it happens by
turning on push alerts inside our 8 News
Now app it's available for download on
both Google Play and the App Store